[Musica]
tutti i titoli del listino è di nuovo a
taiz epica e non distrugge scatola
sbagliata con gli ingredienti slime
dentro e scivolando abbiamo trovato
questo challenge distruggere la scatola
sbagliata e strada etico quella cialde
già deciso di rifare un piano lo stato
di crisi tra l'altro mi chiede in
continuazione quando fate la seconda
parte quella challenge non vi
preoccupate la stiamo organizzando e
presto arriverà la seconda parte in
questo caso per oltre ma rompere le
scatole manette ci sono gli ingredienti
slime line venga cartella muscoli venga
martello dobbiamo scegliere una scatola
è romperlo colpito dovremo mettere
l'ingrediente dentro la nostra ciotola
con la colla
abbiamo anche l'ingrediente è un
disastro ad esempio per quanto riguarda
i coloranti ma soprattutto delle
bottigliette di cole porter e le grandi
tele spacchiamo paura che schizzerà
ovunque avanzato che succederà ora
copertura sarà un disastro sociale così
come è stata divertentissima per noi è
anche per voi siete un bel haj chi se
volete
sale in spazi e consigliate sicurelli
come ti piaccia legge fare quello che
spiace di più il essere un cuoricino e
andremo forte perché non ha mai negato
che mi sa tanto di foto di voi con il
mio libro con il vostro libro in cui
vivete la foto con il libro mi piace sul
tacco in tanti mi avete scritto
lunghezza o che ci fossero così tante
cose perché parlante di me
temple challenge sono anche dei fai da
te ma è commosso slime super contenta
che mi stia piacendo tanto il diritto di
vedere questo video le parole di andare
a vedere il canale l'italia che non si
chiama il canale digitale potrebbe ho
fatto il matrimonio disastro tutto
schermo e iniziamo subisca tabarez è una
che vince rio tinto allora innanzitutto
6 a scatto l'ha trovata sì ma posso
beccare la scatola col martello bendato
no perché magari pezzi
il mio cliente non fate questo gioco a
calcio mi raccomando la sua questo gioco
[Musica]
e che fa è l'arte l'aiuto paura si è
rotta
e un po sembra che questa scatola sia
indistruttibile lo potremo hart lane
rimasta intatta ma vede opposti gli
ingredienti sono rimasti intatti sono
delle scatole orientate sono stato molto
fortunato è spaccata abbiamo il
colorante giallo che pur tonalità rosa
come statici che risponda a questa
proviamo allora ho scelto questa scatola
vediamo se riesco a sfondarla forse no
chiaro to break 3 2 una quasi 3 2 1
ultimo volume di cosa che starò per la
32 don ininterrotti sfondano incredibile
sono resistenti queste scatole ma
vediamo che ingredienti ci sono dentro
che mi piace teatro zeta come un po si è
sfondata ruta allora notare come si
stava sfondando la scatola però il
problema è un altro
l'autorità fortuna sono un po geloso
quello che questo ingrediente meno se le
stime la barba i primi di concetti
chiari però dai ma borchiette
chiederò meriti vanno bene dico sempre
io ultimamente quindi adesso ci sta che
lo prendo il potere andiamo a mettere
poi continuiamo la soul e allora
iniziamo subito con il mio colore
preferito
no
eppure macchia ma chi lo ha aperto così
me lo spieghi sei stato tu sicuramente
dalla nato che non utilizzato è il top
mamma mia ma basta così già il resto è
andato sulla mia mano e apre la mano
verde adesso ama il pollice verde
numeri che già a verde anche se ne metti
poco diventa avvertissimo vabbè da voi
lo vedete colore ammettiamo per fortuna
mi è capitata la schiuma da barba almeno
sotto la barra stelle
cavo o almeno si è schiarito un po il
verde ed il bello comincia subito con il
cavallo il giallo che il mio preferito
si è bellissimo lo slancio al 49 tanti
in mano che non è vero lo guarda già
giallo oro
poi adesso ci mettiamo il tocco e
calista car tocco magico di questi
glitter viola che sono rosa non sono più
la parola rosa viola si sa mai che i
colori sembrano via pc o che bene che
esiste un oggetto è il tocco bellissimo
dei glitter perdona niente mostarda di
importarla allora toccate giocato la
sfida rompere l ho colpito qualcosa però
che cos'è va bene a tre anche questi
stava sfondando mancava poco abbiamo la
soluzione bene che fortuna con il primo
titolo verdi stata anche come il verde e
poi basta grido di non si diventa tutto
colore preferito è il grigio e giallo e
nero diventa utilizzano sei contento no
normale che simone grippo vertical meno
porta un po di colore nero siano le
paure a 0
hai scelto la scatola sbagliata che è
rivitalizzata un po fortunato un po
sfortunato tocca a me allora io vorrei
provare a rompere una scatola piccolo
secondo me se siro 3 2 1 si terrà il
tavolo tra vasto bene abbiamo scatterà
ex per la posso aprire la direttamente
da qua
ho sfondato anche questo o eretta così
guardate e sbeccato tipo non si fa così
o se lo sfondato io comunque sono
tipicamente arancioni sono per fortuna
allora tocca vitale cominciamo subito
con l'adozione dai la loro migliore a
poco a poco a poco non tantissimo
non vedo l'ora di vedere i piccoli
diventa poi mettiamo di bimbi cv proprio
monstar dona ammuffita mostrandone con i
semi poi e poi è finito di bastare a te
la metti magari esce arancione tre gocce
metodo dico quattro perché tutela dei
mezzo chilo
marrone grigio grigio abbiamo fortuna il
giallo da tenuto bene dai più bastardo
farne pigmento bellissimo proprio
arancione sorta di color rop al
bellissimo andare via questo perde tanto
ma non se ne hai detto tu guarda più
forte braccato occupa saranno questo
colore sfumato e che colore è permeata
però insomma questo arancione non va
bene vado da un po e merletti bluff
gli ho preso questa rosa mimmo teresi a
smontarla non c'è niente questa scalata
di questa scala non c'è nulla partiamo
dal rumore non fa rumore non fa rumore
fai vedere
il preferito di entrare il grigia tra
l'altro fosse un pigmento quindi forse
sei fortunato e non colore era troppo
quello da ignoti
il grigio si perseguita come
perseguitando inverte sicurezza dai
funghi poter fondare questa che più
bassa vediamo se le scosse fondare
questa scatola ai piatti preso il mio
mostrandone qui sembra molto solido no
niente super resistente incredibile
vediamo cosa c'è dentro 12 un occhio
fortunato adesso ti va pure bene per
colore il colorante pesca kebili fresca
poi leader viola ma che fortuna questo
turno incredibile e pigmenti viola
notissimo
allora sono rimaste tre scatole prima di
utilizzare questo ingredienti andiamo a
provare a sfondare anche le altre
allora ma certo nessuno chi riesce a
sfondare un mercato lo prende la terza
perché sono tre
quindi sono dispari per ora io sono
riusciti a sfondare una quindi
spetterebbe a mettersi to riches
fondarne un'altra tutto a te va bene
allora io ci avevo quest'ultimo i nomi
sono fortunata dai grossi come sfondato
questa prenderei anche la terza guardate
state recapitate le briciole di pane o e
di scrittore
sono almeno con la sostanza ci fanno
bene
[Applauso]
quindi vediamo solo scappate e io riesco
sfondarlo nel prossimo scatolato camera
terzo scatto non ci riesco spettante per
che si distaccano l'ultimo ascoltato ma
andiamo attraverso forse questa piccola
non c'è niente di cattivo perché
piccolina però dovrebbe esserci infatti
la canalis è coperta piccola allora
vediamo chi spetterà poi quella ten
[Musica]
no è indistruttibile
vediamo cosa s'era detto quindi la terza
aspettate di fortunate che fate valere
il pattino molto è il mento verde fino a
mayfair decapitato due date capitato di
cristo che dorme riuscito ad una volta
alberto aguero garanti più il grid di
capitale dovrebbero dare per la terza
scatola che abbiamo detto che lui tipo
che la sfondava rispettava la terza
scatola palline
basta del grigio inter crisi perché alle
prese da emotorace bene le palline
vabbè allora cominciamo indiano
potenziando col grigio canna di fucile
il pigmento la sua area ma il destino
voleva proprio tutto compromessa crisi
no secondo me diventa giallo 1 dalle
zampe che già lo tiene mostarda questore
resistere poi mettiamo le mie preferite
o comunque con le fiches volti spalline
potrebbe uscire qualcosa di molto craxi
mettiamo le pose che tanto poi lo so
bene perdono attivo stanno bene se le
prime del giallo sono diventate serve
acqua nel frattempo abbiamo messo e
facebook poi andiamo in ordine mettiamo
il glitter grigio non tanto è a posto
beh comunque mantiene ancora il suo il
suo colore da moscardo ne mostrano
ok il giallo basta noi non lo giusta
diventato grigio anche se sempre dai
vertici e pallini perché vuoi bambini
vuol dire 4 nord e donato con la pallina
e o belliraj molto stato tratto davvero
bastavano i semi io sono super contento
del mio slime guarda che bello come una
cattiva e giallo un po verde un po
grigio con i punti con i puntini sono
proprio curiosa di vedere come diventa
allora data fortunata quell ora mettiamo
il colore pesca che mi piace in estate
lo vediamo come diventa perché non so
pesca più verde roma gola e di euro
oddio sembra che stia scomparendo che
strano è diventato un addio sembra un po
grigio effettivamente o 10 maggio al
grigiore al grigio non a kakà ex ribelli
è diventato il mio grido è un po
violetto dai tardiola per fortuna questo
belli di contatto belli qua poco ma
vabbè poi il pigmento viola speriamo che
dia un bel tocco di colore viola feriti
bello
[Musica]
un bel colore tanto tempo forse diventa
viola no diventa grigio gli effetti non
lo so non è molto sospetta non è finita
qua perché dobbiamo mettere il pigmento
verde che non si apre forse non abbiamo
mai usato questo che adesso diventerà
ancora più verde
[Musica]
adesso tornavento arte
no no ancora grigio dal grigio che
riflessi verdi
ma rovinato il colore iniziale era
meglio del nuovo verde per la mette ecco
che i nostri 3 1 dai colori molto strani
allora andiamo ad attivarli e poi vi
facciamo vedere potrete votare in base
al suono e il battello aspetto agisce
fronti 3 32 ora da google news live
gruppo pinault viscosa perché non lo
volevo attivare troppo alla fine a
maliziosi dell'utilizzo al colpito né me
né a chi dove e non vitale se non si
possa credere che da quel verde da quel
viola è uscito questo grigio bianco
guardate come è possibile che sono
spariti quei colori sono spariti
completamente allora però devo dire che
il booking e fantastico
allora in realtà il colore e la
consistenza e fatto che siano costituite
accordato la superficie della luna
guardate sembra una nonna live luna
proviamo a farlo tondo
ecco qua lo slime alluda devo dire che
il porting è perfetto però figli il
colore è un po particolari non è niente
di che
ecco qua quindi questo soprannominato ma
vedi rumore come diventata pubblica e
per i pochi nel meglio del buio speriamo
che ci prova in cura i nuovi tornitore
tutto quanto è bello allora vi presento
lo slime monstar dona stranamente lo
attivato non bene molto bene
nessuna delle fiches bo è caduta nessuna
delle fiches bollo è caduta e sono
rimasto sorpreso anch'io
e a questi colori bellissimi pro
mostarda ogni tanto a tre dei riflessi
grigie dei dei riflessi verdi poi
possiamo notare tutte le palline
piccoline piccoline che sembrano appunto
disegni di mostarda e tutti i glitter
colorati verdi grigi viola bellissimo è
davvero bellissimo sentiamo i pochi che
adesso apprendiamo normale imparate ad
attivarli bene
ebbene sì dopo il mio 181esimo online ma
sono riuscito ad attivarli bene niente
sono davvero contento perché mi
si da il mio povero fabio storie no
senti bisogna allora secondo me ti
aspetto meglio il tuo cielo per history
di famiglia il mio allora ora tocca con
tempi di cottura rapido si super morbido
però si attacca alle milani mattinata
tra le mie mani ma che guarda il 2
trattativa non è vero no mi rimane
troppo passato non idonea il mio più
bello è interrotto attiva no non è vero
il prodotto bene ad attivarli cosa aveva
già tutti è in casino ti si attacca
grazie alla prova i pochi visto che
differenza lui foto indumento quello di
anita però dice vitale ha dei ritmi
diverbi tra banco molto bello anche il
tuo ho fatto uno swirl di come ho
imparato a farli adesso perfetto
che mai non lo so è troppo morbida non
riesco a farlo lo svizzero perfetto
allora ragazzi votate mondiale che ha
ispirato lo slide già un fatto scontato
filippi ma con questa striscia ma grigia
guardate fare mi piace di più votate chi
ha vinto quattro casse di pubblicare nel
progetto alla prima fishbowl gli altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
nel borsone